une au dos et squeeze aujourd'hui on se
trouve sur mike blake c'est un jeu
d'horreur assez cool alors apparemment
on va devoir tourner ses pages pour
choisir un jour de la semaine
vous jouez un petit enfant qui doit
protéger sa famille ainsi que lui même
d'une infestation de night lights sur
des créatures dégueulasse nos cousins
survivre jusqu'au petit matin quand le
soleil réapparaît donc apparemment pour
pâques les monstres s'énerve m bouffe je
dois nourrir à base de jouer moi c'est
parti on va jouer le lundi alors on y va
il y à un night lights ou le lie au
[ __ ] sous le lit de ma soeur et de mon
père souviens toi de les nourrir avec
tes jouets qui a déjoué par tout ça qui
est bien plus tard alors fonds pourris
gâtés
il ya un million de jouer partout
protège ta famille jusqu'à 7 heures du
matin bonne chance à moi ok moi à moi
j'ai trouvé la technique j'ai vu un
matelas sont au lit voilà y'a pas de
mike blake abdallah comme ça ok alors
attendez on prend se jouer par exemple
il ya un bruit un bruit et un truc c'est
ouvert dont il y avait un bruit il y en
a un là non waouh on le voit même pas
quoi [ __ ] c'est chiant à je crois que
le lit des parents ou de la petite heure
était en bas il est là bas il est
terrifiant un terrifiant aulas tient
hockey en plus les dressings comme ça
ils souffrent et du coup voilà je ne les
refermer double objectif roi et le frigo
à saint flour be voilà c'est drôle quand
même regarder y en a d'autres regardez
le wali mange pas des jouer mon jeu des
ponts gros burger
regarde toi j'ai entendu il est apprécié
qui s'est ouvert elle c'est horrible
donc mes parents n'ont pas de visage ça
qu'est bon je suis fils caché de
voldemort mais pourquoi ça se souvient
rien dedans et d'attaquant ok moi je
nourris plus s'avance en fait sous lis
ça vient avec notes au pouce
je veux pas être mangés tu seras manger
auto pousse à te pousse et si je fais un
stock de nourriture je mets plein de
jouets comme sa côte à côte à temps là
je veux dire elle a deux joué il a de
quoi se nourrir pendant deux trois
heures est capable car il va pas me
poser je suis un chat on sur [ __ ] de
charges sociales sur le canapé comme ça
vous plaît trop manger si tu seras
manger donc 99,99 désolé désolé désolé
wata fog octopus tu vas était trop belle
et maintenant il va être mangé et ta
gueule tu là ta gueule qu'elle me
tourner
vos parents sont morts en fait je mets
des joues il ne mange pas des fois tu
vas y fais chier mais j'ai trouvé un
truc de fou la voyez mange pas moche
tient bêta non non mais là tu avais pas
moi je suis choqué ne faisons pas de
visage pâle et stagne alors à nous rien
du du najd mais quand j'arrive pas à
dire ce [ __ ] donc ou quand il
s'appelle en fait je pense que je peux
pas nourrir tant qu'il sait pas assez
avancée sous le lit moyen des loyers
c'est un petit peu avancé je pense que
je peux déjà peut-être le nourrir même
tiens voilà c'est ma monture et vaty
scheubel s'en est toute chaude sur lui
il m'envoie en l'air howie b à cette
idée mais je peux prendre ça pour
accéder à un chai trucks ont propulsé en
plus voilà 0 à cheval puis au dessus du
monde c'est la coupe du monde du saut en
hauteur
cette fois le bébé est prêt à s'élancer
il monte sur le tabouret et il va cette
fois un moyen d co et tu vas te calmer
direct comment je triche c'est génial
pourquoi montée des marches qu'on peut
voler sur un tabouret c'est vrai non non
non pourquoi je me suis au volet trop
chaud sur le toit wendel oh [ __ ] c'est
quoi ce foutu reicha mais papa et maman
viens avec moi octopus mais qu'est ce
que tu fais et se traite à gueule c'est
bon réseau tour dans la maison c'était
un peu plus il avait trouvé la planque a
vendu en plus quoi il se cache et
carrément des créatures pas du tout
solidaire nous a rien dit allez voilà on
lui a croqué ces molécules
quelle heure est-il madame persil 19h45
monsieur placard c'est vrai en plus ah
ouais et ouais milliards qu'il vous a
pris lénaïg là ce sont des créatures
mortelles que seuls les enfants peuvent
voir le goût de bébé les remplit de joie
quoi c'est glauque [ __ ] s'il
grandissent près de lui le bébé pleurera
en ont fait tourner le bourg le jouer à
bebela au dessus de lui et le bébé ne
m'aura pas la porte du garage doit tout
verte et vous les entendrez respirer si
c'est le cas ça veut dire qu'il y en ait
blind qui est pas loin
le cap et sur le bouton rouge pour
fermer la porte [ __ ] on a galéré pour
le bel art assis là il va pas du tout
être facile à c'est mon frère voilà qui
va pleurer peut pas m'aider lui aussi la
salle puis c'est un [ __ ] de nounours
voilà on comprend pourquoi les parents
n'ont pas de visage vous comprends
qu'ils adoption attends t'es là au bras
avait donc annoncé sa peluche plus petit
frère c'est ça ce morceau de textures là
à jour et pêchu et mon petit frère à ça
c'est sûr elles optent eux poussent bien
là mais pourquoi toujours moi parce que
tu m'attire c'est comme ça mais où
je sais mais tentacules ouais tu veux me
pécho le canon et stan de place elle est
où la porte du garage ok quel est le
fait qu'elle est ok y'a comme valeur qui
jouent en délire ce sera en fait
j'essaie d'ouvrir la porte et complète à
non mais je sens que je vais pas du tout
la passe et c'est depuis quoi s'est il
ya beaucoup trop de trucs là j'arrive
petit frère tu pourra toujours compter
sur moi toute ta vie je suis à gauche un
exemplaire voté et adopté chez ingres
enfin exemplaires aux mondiaux il imite
pas de quoi faut faire quoi je comprends
peuvent faire quoi est fait rien mon
petit frère et je vais détruire la
mâchoire direct [ __ ] mais je vois pas
comment allumer là le truc qui tourne là
à temps alors ça c'est scandaleux ça
déjà ok j'abandonne je me casse au
revoir [ __ ] c'est moi la messe était
sûre il allait rentrer par garage ça
c'est waouh
il a voulu me tuer [ __ ] il a été
corrompue par les knights
je retiens jamais leur nom il faut que
je montre comment on course est mort il
va le oui au oui le couture mon père
siffleur vis de moi je vote et je
cherchais teintées frais à ses premiers
mon gars tu peux compter sur moi on tour
le nay bled qui a faim mais il ya des
jouets devant toi sers toi comment ça va
petite soeur je ferai toujours là pour
toi c'est quoi demander ta gueule c'est
à fond du garage chez bruit plus tard
vite ou tuer vous rentrez non non ils
sont pas rentrés c'est fort ils veulent
nous faire croire ça mais non ils sont
pas là ces fleurs vie puis trappe rôle à
la dame est sûr est que les gens me
souhaitent au travail la télé un truc a
fait en même temps c'est infernal
j'ai besoin de toi
la bombe rouge à moi en fait là le bébé
qu'on joue c'est le gardien en fin
d'atelier soit elle était enfant il
était déjà en train de passer ses nuits
à surveiller des trucs la rude vie de
merde lui a permis du monde avant que
peu moi ta faim
alors comment vas-tu petites fleurs ça
se passe la nuit tranquille tu fais de
beaux rêves bah écoute moi je vais
crever puisque je dors jamais mis que
cinq minutes serait mort mais elle me
fait ch ya cette somme et ceci est la
dernière [ __ ] de lui si un problème
technique de jeu ce soir quéquette ça
dégage après immédiatement de jouer à ce
jeu vous allez vous mettre juste là
devant le night bidule je n'arrive pas à
retenir leur nom je fais un blocage
c'est quoi ça au attend encore des
comores et appelle à la tête là d'un
coup sec
j'arrive petite soeur petit frère pardon
a été adoptée je sais mais ce n'est pas
comme ça un petit frère je suis là voilà
tu vas faire quoi me bien traités petit
frère dors bien
edward aux mains d'argent ce qui était
une coûte 1000 que moi de me dit frère
tu es non je suis la petite pas je
t'aime ne s'en fait pas ouais la couche
du québécois j'ai pu trouver sur la
lingue à puce québécois mais pas trop
non plus quoi l'accent est pas et pour
présent avec moi et choisit mabon dit
monsieur comme ça il a fait de la gym et
tout sur ce nom mais [ __ ] sur night
lights j'étais assis vous a plu c'est le
carnet de tpm f2 comme d'habitude
le principe est mignon ça reprend
peuvent pas bien tu as de frais 10 mais
bon c'est pas fou c'est pas folichon non
plus hein tu permets de rimbaud face au
tour de vis dans une prochaine vidéo
merci d'avoir regardé le châtiment bis
[Musique]